NEWS.REAKING
U TOWHERE
YOU CAN SEE LIVE FROM THE
PICTURES, THE COURT IS BACK IN
RA.
ARE YOU HEARING?
>>HAT, WHAT WE
NG ESSENTIALLY IS THE
ASSEMBLING OF EVERYONE YOU
INO MOVES INDICTMENTROUGH THE P
TO GO THROUGH.
AGN,E WAIN
WHAT TPROVIDED.
BACKN AND  WTIBACK OBENCH, THATR
TO SEE WHAT THE GRANJURY HAS
TO HAND OFF TO THE JUDGE.OW THAR
HE CLERK'S OFFIC
EVER TY DECIO  WHATEVER THE GRA
UP, IT GETS HANDED
JUDGE BENIE THISTHE PRESIDESTROW
HEDS OFF ON ANY
POTENTIAL INDICTMES.SE INDICTS
TO BE WALKED INTO THCOCLERK'S O
BE STAMPED, WHERE THEY CAN BE
SED.
SO, AS WE AREING THESE FOL
ASSEMBLE, WE'RE SEEING THEGE
WEE SEEING THEW UP
IN THE CLERK'S OFFICE.
WHAT WE ARE ESSENTIAY YONE GOINS
THEDR TONT, E WE AWAIT WD OF WH
GRAND JURY HAS ACTUA
UP, GUYS.
>> SARA, JUS O
AUN THAT ROOM?CREEN, ROOM WHEREH
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY NOT SEEING THE
THAT'S JUST THE RES, HE JUDGE.
WHO HAVE BEEN SITTING
THERE WAG CORRECT?
>>IGHTCAN'T SEE THOMT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT RIGHT, ANDERSON,
CATHINK WHAT YOU'RE LOOKIN
McBERNIE'SOU.Y JUDGE ROBER
REPORTERS ARE NOT ALLOWE
THE ROOM WHERE THEND JURY
NORMALLY C THE
HAVE BEEHEG FROM WITNESSES
BUN SITTING
BE
COURTROOM ALL DAWAITING FOR T T
WRAPPINGP,OR ANY
WORD THAT THE GRAND JUAS ANY TH
TO HAND UP TO THIS
JUDGE TODAY, ANDERSOND THEN  SO
HEAR FTHL HEARROE JUDGE
YEAH.
IT'S SOROFP TO EVERY
ES THEY TO HANDLE THESE GSKNOW,
EY'RE IN THIS POSITION JUST
GET A STACK OF PAPERS.EY SIGD TH
DON'T AN ABOUT IT.WE'RE WAITING
GOING TO SAY ANYTHING,
PRUMABLY WHEHE
AY PRESIDING JUDGE HAS A
T OF LEEWATO SORT OF DECIDE
HE WA IN THISATION.
E WAITING TO SEE
JUDGE ROBERT McBERNIE --
>> IT LOLIKE THE CLERK IS
PAPERWORK NOW, SARA.ELIE HOENIG
, I'M SEEING -- - OUR LEGAL ANA.
RE WE
>> SS T HERE.
APPEARS TO BE THE
STAG.T ECUTOR WHO'SN
PROCEEDINGS, AFTER THE G AS VOTN
INDICTMENT, WOULLK
TO T
WE SAW SOMEONE SIGNING P A TRANS
ME IT IN OPEN COURT.
THE JURY, FO
LITERALLY HAND UP THE
INDICTMENT.
THAT'S WHY WE USE THE HAND UP AN
THE WILL REVIETHEM
IT'S JUSA FOAL
IM
WILLTHS.
OUT IS WHEE DOCUMENTS HIPUIC NE
W EXACTLY THE
PEOPLE
BUT, AGAIN, YOU WOULD TAKE THE
FOREPERSON AS A PROSECUTOR
WITH THAPERSON TO THE
CLK EN TJUE,AMPING HAPPENING.
C SO, ILIKE THAT WOULD
VID
TO TOWARD THE DGE.
. SAF
>> WOULD WEL.
SOTIE JUDGE WILL DO THIS
FF  IN THE
COURTROOM.
UA
THE PERSON JUST WALKS UP A THESO
ANYBODY.
TO DO THISEHIN DOORS
INIT'S REALLY UP T  THAT.
SARIS
COT, NOT THE GRAND
JURY ROOM.
YOU WOULD NEVER HAVE A CAMERA S.
I DON'T THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN.
TO BE EXPECTING SOME SORT NOUNCG
AND THE JUDGE COULD WELL DO THAT
AN WE'VE  T
CTTOMBER
SUCH ANDF GEORGI
VERSUS WHOEVER.
ALSFO GEORGIA FED
L MOORE ISH US.
HING USABOUT AND JURY  HAPPE WE
FOREPERSON COMING IN WITTHE
ECUTORO, INDICTMEN PR OPEN
COTHOUSE IS TO
BES TO B
E JUDGE D FOREPERSON, THE PRESEH
INDICTMENT HAND UPOU
TO MAKE SUSIGNED
PRS AND THINGS.
AND RETURN COURTS
PP
HET ST,
IT.IOUSLY, T JL AC
DOO THE
K  PUB
DOCKET AND AT THOI WE'REF TO TH
MATTER OF TIME BEFOR A
IT'L IO SEE  TRACKS E  IER POST
FEDERAL JUDGE.
INDICTMENT BANHEHAEL, THIS -- IS
JUDGE, C?AN'T SEE IT, BUT THAT S
HAPPENG THE I THE THERE, JN TH'
IN.SOUNINN WE L
AS IT SHOULD H FRONT OF
>> Y. ALL. EX YE PREPAR AK
I' CLERK.
YOU'LLAINTAIN CUSTODY OF IFROM ?
.R
HIS GOM RIGHT.
K CH., >>ESU O.T, YOU MAKE WA